whoo hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome to top bear oh
that started the game okay I guess we're
going into it hey so you're a flying
bear going over the forest and I can oh
I have no idea alright alright I'm dumb
okay well I didn't know you see how I
didn't know you see how that happened
you see yeah this is me knowing over
here and his weight everybody back up a
step I feel like I got I feel like I got
rushed I'd like to take my time first I
want to appreciate the adorable bear in
there that's nice that is nice Z - Ozzie
to shoot Z ah see I see now okay now
we're on the same page now I get you
okay alright let's do this I'm dead but
you know that's just how you start the
game first the first it starts out with
the enviro bear where a bear's driving
and now a bear has to fly oh oh oh god I
love bullet-hell is so much I really do
i I don't know what it is about it just
um for some whoa hello okay doing there
are you doing there sonny jim
yeah tvs at me i just notice that but uh
yeah I used to play it like endlessly
when I was when I was a kid and I was
growing up like a lot of it what I
didn't hit that did I hit that to do it
when I was a kid I growing up like a lot
of the games in the early 90s were swaps
which were mob saying I don't remember
the anagram of shmups but it
shoot-'em-ups that's what it is and you
cuz you go up and you shoot him makes
sense of course it makes sense and
everything I say makes sense I don't
even know what those gift back
oh it's honey oh I'm a bear oh I'm
getting buckets of money that are flying
in the sky
but I haven't been it yet so I guess I
don't need them or something like that I
don't know blues I don't know what those
are all about but I'm trapped it alright
didn't have been there shouldn't have
been there okay
yeah targeting targeting targeting Oh
miss me douche nozzle
I'm gonna get that honey just because I
can mister in my life I'm alright okay
so oh is that like a zombie bear or
something no that's dangerous okay
that's bad of a bad bad bad
Oh Oh God Oh guys could really use a
controller for this bad boy because this
is the last ain't gonna do nothing for
me come on reaction times of a Phoenix
which I can only assume is very fast
also when I die I come back to haunt you
which is what a Phoenix does right guys
that's right
I don't know wow that's perfect sorry I
got a cur Oh tracker oh it's my favorite
thing about shmups is the fact that it's
gone I guess but alright whatever is the
fact that they were off hey whoa whoa
whoa that hurt a lot I got three hits
off of that that's stupid you're stupid
will you be bastards trying to keep me
from a honey oh I'm getting cornered not
today I miss my honey pot I didn't I
didn't get hit which ya win in my book
you do okay come area batch what the
hell did I get hit twice on that bar
honey
come on get in my mouth I've never
shouted that freely at the top of my
lungs before but get in my mouth
alright good more honey I'll take that
and I get that ooh honey and whatever
the hell that is I think that's a leg oh
whoa oh oh mama bear
mama bear you mad Paul you mad mama bear
too bad I got superpowers barely here
later Lee oh Gong angry or something
Oh
little dude I'm dumb ah nah ah now you
sack of [ __ ] you think you go I got it
pretty tough it's hard to do precise
controls with a keyboard but oh what are
you doing over no I'm gonna get that
you're not gonna keep it from me cuz I'm
great and you're oh no oh no one more
right there oh damn you to hell oh I
guess sir well I'm gonna do it but
because it's fun but god damn you and
your face you big bear oh I got no
better insults for a bear I don't know
what really hurts your feelings so I
can't really I can't really just gasp
you know I don't wanna I'm gonna be
cruel about it I miss that honey but I
didn't need it so oh damn it oh is this
a permanent upgrade oh that's nice
that's lovely or maybe want to get hit
that's usually the typical fashion of
this but one of my favorites mops from
1990 was Raptor any of you guys have
ever played Raptor those it's an old
game I probably it's available on Good
Old Games maybe I have no idea but it
was great game love that game played it
so much the upgrade ability of it hey
this was back like there wasn't really a
store like Steam didn't exist so when I
when my dad got it for me he had to send
in like a letter to the game company and
be like right send me one of these I
sign in a magazine like that's how you
bought doom back in the days you just
sickly wrote him a letter and millions
millions of people do all this
wait what it's randomly generated oh I
love that they're not gonna get me right
all right oh that's beautiful it's a
thing of beauty beautiful butter full
its butter its butter butter in my face
alright come on ba ba ba my mama bear
you remember I said that you got nothing
that's still true apparently I got hit
whoever it don't matter
hey stop being invincible that's right
that's right that's right that's how you
do that's how you do it that's how you
do I tell you ok minute honey oh yeah oh
yeah
Oh your dad oh you're so dead this
upgrade sure came in handy I [ __ ] dog
a cookie oh you're dead I'm an idiot
I could have dodged everything there but
I was like just a few more it's Oh Eddie
god damn you
give me the Apple stop dangle it in
front of my face just eat it dick
trade you to Apple for it Dutch dick no
I don't want a dick I'm saying an apple
like I'll give you it no you know this
that doesn't sound good anyway I'm gonna
shut up while I'm ahead
oh I'm not ahead ok whatever please it
seems to be getting me closer to the
boss sooner which is nice distraction it
gets really cool legitimately cool I
just find it fun frustrating but fun I
could add it on the first try but then I
decided to be stupid about my life just
like it was there for some reason I went
to get the honey and I got hit on the
way so the honey is actually a net watch
come on good bad
come on come on oh yeah that's that's a
good stuff right there
or all right let's oh I can't hit that
guy okay well that solves AK out out why
I am such a oh no I'm such a fart I did
it again
god dammit I'm I just kept whomping into
him cuz I'm dumb I got this you guys
don't think I got this but I got this
these poor birds you know these birds
are just flying along pretty much
everything here is just flying along
there's only a few things that actually
want to kill me
these bees and birds you know it's
trying to live their life and then I
come along not good all around not good
no please let me live please let me
actually show that I'm halfway decent at
this [ __ ]
alright now bear lady bear lady bear
lady come on now bear lady rumpus rumpus
war ha ha the extreme canons not obey
invincible that's not fair to me oh yeah
that's the good stuff
oh yeah ok you died no I right into it
really I jump right into it I'm I'm just
a goddamn idiot no my Wampus oh god if
that would have been son of a tent
Winkle son of a biscuit Blanc er son of
a
Oh am i old I'm all the way back at the
beginning aren't I it's not even it's
not even being nice so out of a trainees
Bronco hum will get you no no well
barely I'm not I just fire in a straight
line I should be fine right Oh whale
uh-oh whoa ha nope okay honey ha right
bye see ya honey didn't need you hi
honey I did I lied what I said I didn't
need it the actual fact what I needed
very extremely alright oh yeah that's
the good stuff
okay all right fair all right bear your
freaking bear here here we go we're
gonna go we're gonna go ahead Tinseltown
bear baby I got it
I'm gonna take it a tango and you're not
gonna like it
oh no um oh we're firm so scary
am i you who I'm watching like a house
like the Phoenix yeah my rise from the
dead every time you think you got rid of
man like a now you're wrong cuz about
Who I am that's what the what is that
that is god damn you you know what Wow
yeah that's right yeah that's right yeah
that's right Oh nope nah I'm being
stupid not again okay class this is all
skill right here watch it watch my skill
you guys seeing my scope hey how's it
going friend oh yeah oh yeah that's
that's that's the opposite of good sound
like I need this upgrade it's not like I
need the upgrade obviously I don't
because I'm cool and stuff boy that
lucky yeah it's good thing this games
fun and feels good that's the thing
about shmups kind of good game feel
except little look even the keyboard
controls you know it's not that bad cuz
it's got just the right amount of
momentum - it's real smooth experiences
to talk about the game for a second I
love the way the shadows play out also
this game reminds me a critical
annihilation just cos same exact sound
like the voxel eat whatever it is style
fever which I haven't played critical
annihilation oh I love to play that
again
I'm gonna have to play one finger death
punch again oh it's been so long
god I'd love one finger death punch oh
god I got to play that again might do
another video of it do you guys want to
see another
one Finger Death Punch I used to do it
like every because it was like mice go
to stress reliever game cuz it was just
so mindless but also it required a lot
of mind and it was a fun very satisfying
like the visceral nosov it that's what
that's what I mean by good game feel
like that is game that is great game
field just because it responds so
smoothly that's beautiful it's a thing
of beauty
I see I got the triple drink trade
minister I'm around you load this bear
up with drinks a surprise a primary like
this bears flying this blasted drunk
okay I got you I got you and you got me
cuz we are there for each other okay
here we go is where are things good okay
I see I see I see that shadow you think
I didn't see that shadow huh yeah I saw
that shadow oh I saw that shadow all
right your dad your dad oh it's not over
oh there's more oh yeah I love this
right this time I actually got my eye in
so I'm gonna actually do not terribly
another apple juice I'm super powerful
I'm so powerful look at me look at me
look at a powerful eye Schuster oh god
don't even try get out of my way I love
it I love it the see ah it's so weird
and blocky but alright oh it's so cool
well the music got a lot more high if I
don't know if that's actually gonna pay
off for anything but okay cuz I mean I I
mean I'm not saying the music's bad I'm
just saying I'm not gonna live up to the
height that's a story of my life like I
I just don't do that there if there ever
is hype I'm like well I can't do that if
I'm ever up to like win an award I'm
like oh my god [ __ ] off of here I hate
that oh that's right yeah so like funny
thing about that I won a golden joystick
which like I've heard of the golden
joysticks and like it's super cool I
guess
but I didn't even know who I just know
who do you think that they would be
good job there you should know about
that but again like I just I can't be
bothered I don't give a place it's not
like I'm ungrateful it's just like oh
god what do I do I just
I play video games and I make mediocre
videos so just give it an award to
someone that actually like does
something with their life whoa whoa whoa
it's a big cloud oh no it's a bear but
what is it the whale in the ocean
oh I didn't even see those I can't see
[ __ ]
I cannot I couldn't see [ __ ] stop
spitting at me a white whale it's too
shiny for me alright we got the same
colored bullets how am I gonna be able
to tell why can't survive another one of
those you beam bastard bastard what if
I'm up and left no see what's what's not
damn you and oh is that a bacon ooh
tiny bullets tiny bullets I guess that's
good is that like a permanent thing
permanent alright it's not as effective
I mean it's effective more like direct
hitting them but at the same time I need
to dodge oh I think I know what that
beam did that beam doesn't damage me it
just makes it hard to see what I'm
dodging that's the problem of this boss
is legitimately the challenges you can't
really see
okay I see what they ups oh that was
just me being bad i overshot that i
meant to go for the the thing but uh
then i didn't see how i sucked all right
okay I see how you work white whale and
now I'm gonna kick your uh blood okay
I'm gonna kick your ass
oh no oh god damn it why me huh fine
then [ __ ] I'll kick your ass again
now kick the whales ass sure do love
chicken ass okay all the way back and
burn up alright okay I'm done just
alibies okay so that is top bear I could
have done better at that but I didn't
see only explanation yeah but this game
is awesome love it I love this game I
don't know where it ends I don't know
how many levels there are but it's
pretty fun so I'll leave a link in the
description I believe it's free play it
for yourselves thank you everybody so
much for watching let me know he thought
down the comments below and as always I
will see you in the next video
[Music]